neue fieber ambulanzen im ganzen land
und massenweise schnelltests deutschland
rüstet sich für den corona herbst neuer
vorwurf in der wirecard affäre die
aufsichtsbehörde bafin hat den konzern
offenbar nur schlampig kontrolliert und
wenn der nähe zur tödlichen bedrohung
wird der sudan im nordosten afrikas
erlebt die schlimmsten überschwemmungen
seit jahrzehnten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten mit dabei für den
sport von arbeit leben ein stück von mir
die zahlen steigen kontinuierlich
weltweit auch in deutschland immer mehr
menschen stecken sich mit dem corona
virus an obwohl es derzeit ja noch warm
ist
in herbst und winter wenn sich unser
leben vor allem in innenräumen abspielt
wird es weit mehr fälle geben warnen
fachleute mit neuen maßnahmen will die
bundesregierung das virus in schach
halten
vor allem münchen steht unter zugzwang
der grund hier gab es in einer woche
55,9 fälle je 100.000 einwohner
deshalb dürfen sich ab donnerstag nur
noch fünf personen in der öffentlichkeit
treffen
es sei denn es handelt sich nur um zwei
verschiedene haushalte oder eltern
treffen sich mit ihren kindern oder
großeltern mit ihren enkeln dann dürfen
es auch mehr sein und für stark besuchte
orte wie marienplatz oder
viktualienmarkt gibt es künftig eine
masken pflicht anselm stern so richtig
schön war es heute in der bayerischen
landeshauptstadt spätsommer beste wiesn
zeit eigentlich denn aktuell ist münchen
deutschlands größter corona hotspot seit
tagen und mit folgen
die stadt zieht die notbremse will
kontakte drastisch reduzieren
für mich als gewählter oberbürgermeister
dieser stopp für 1,5 millionen menschen
verantwortlich und muss abwägung
zwischen den interessen der wirtschaft
der gastronomie und der allgemeinen
gesundheit der münchner wünschen und ich
möchte dringend und baldmöglichst nicht
mehr der höchste hotspot in der
bundesrepublik sein
neue regeln in münchen auch weil die
geltenden gerne mal untergehen vor allem
bei privaten feiern
die konsequenz auch in anderen
bayerischen städten kommt für einige
plätze wohl sehr bald eine masken
pflicht innerhalb von sozusagen
professionell organisierten
veranstaltungen sowohl die gastronomen
als auch bei kultur sind hygiene
konzepte die funktionieren auch die sind
überprüfbare werden auch kontrolliert
das problem sind die unzähligen privaten
veranstaltungen auch das treffen auf
plätzen bayern besonders betroffen doch
auch in anderen teilen des landes
steigen die neuinfektionen auf täglich
1750 im schnitt der vergangenen woche
und der herbst ist im anmarsch und mit
ihm auch noch die normale grippewelle
der gesundheitsminister verspricht mehr
schnelltests und mehr anlaufstellen für
erkrankte es geht darum eine
infrastruktur zu haben die sicherstellt
dass nicht im gesundheitswesen im
wartezimmer sich die menschen
untereinander anstecken und deswegen
braucht es schwerpunkt sprechstunden
schwerpunktpraxen oder auch fieber
ambulanzen regional die richtig gute
nachricht die deutschen krankenhäuser
sind vorbereitet sie melden zur stunde
gut 9400 freie intensivbetten ein zdf
spezial zur aktuellen lage senden wir
direkt im anschluss an diese heute
-sendung in unserer zdf heute erfahren
sie welche deutschen regionen besonders
betroffen sind und wo neue corona
verschärfungen drohen
wie kommt man in corona zeiten sicher
durch die kälteren monate
wichtig ist dass auch für schulen und
kitas die soll möglichst nicht noch mal
flächendeckend schließen
kinder dürfen nicht die verlierer der
pandemie sein sagt kanzlerin merkel und
berät mit den bildungsministerien und
ministern über konzepte zur masken
pflicht und über hygiene vorkehrungen
außerdem geht es um den ausbau der
digitalisierung im gespräch sind eine
internet flat internet flatrate fürs
online lernen zu hause und leihgeräte
für bedürftige schüler lehrer sollen
dienstcomputer bekommen kosten
500 millionen euro die kanzlerin
spd-chefin esken ministerinnen und
minister seit einer stunde beraten sie
alle gemeinsam
theo koll in berlin erwartet man den
heute konkrete beschlüsse er ja denn
neben der für schulen ja gar nicht
zuständigen kanzlerin und der spd-chefin
sind eben auch alle kultusministerin
versammelt einerseits will man versuchen
die hygiene bedingungen zu verbessern
beispielsweise sind testzentren für
erkältete kinder angedacht oder lehrer
sollen zur hygienebeauftragten
ausgebildet werden der schwerpunkt
dürfte aber die digitale versorgung der
schulen sein und da liegen ja eine reihe
von vorschlägen auf dem tisch die eben
erwähnten dienstcomputer für lehrer und
leihgeräte für bedürftige schüler
außerdem sollen die schulen schnellere
internetverbindungen bekommen und die
bundesbildungsministerin verhandelt
offensichtlich im moment mit telekom
firmen über günstige schüler tarife
damit der digitale unterricht zu hause
nicht am geld scheitert noch sind das
alles nur ideen mal sehen was hier heute
abend wirklich beschlossen wird vielen
dank der in vielen unserer nachbarländer
steigen die krone zahlen schneller es
bei uns zum beispiel in tschechien
nachdem das land die pandemie im
frühjahr gut im griff hatte sprechen
experten nun von einer zweiten welle
die neuinfektionen erreichten ende der
vergangenen woche einen rekordwert von
mehr als 3100 und jetzt ist auch noch
gesundheitsminister beute zurückgetreten
britta hilpert
die hauptstadt prag ist tschechiens
corona hotspot hier steckt jeder
infizierte fast zwei weitere an
seit tagen vermeldet tschechien
höchststände bei den neuinfektionen im
ganzen land sind es nun fast 50.000
infizierte bei rund zehn millionen
einwohnern
sie haben corona zuletzt wohl nicht
ernst genug genommen
dieses ganze hackmack drumherum hat
keine logische begründung wenn man die
statistiken anschaut dann sieht man dass
es alles humbug ist die menschen kommen
wir eher verwirrt vor als dass sie angst
hätten
mich stört dass vor den ferien soweit
gelockert wurde
man hatte sich doch schon an den
mundschutz gewöhnt mit schulbeginn
verschärfte tschechien seine maßnahmen
wieder oberschüler müssen nun im
klassenzimmer masken tragen bars und
restaurants müssen um mitternacht
schließen und nur an tischen darf
serviert und masken frei getrunken
werden im öffentlichen nahverkehr wie in
allen öffentlichen innenräumen herrscht
nun masken pflicht es reicht wohl nicht
musste der gesundheitsminister zu geben
er tritt heute zurück wie die mit wo sie
betrifft euro pro ich möchte platz
machen für einen neuen lösungsansatz der
korona virus epidemie die uns ja noch
eine weile begleiten wird
tschechien hatte auf die erste
infektionswelle mit einem strikten
lockdown reagiert die wirtschaft brach
um 10 prozent ein
aus wirtschaftlichen gründen lehnt
deshalb die regierung bisher einen
zweiten lockdown ab prag will punktuell
reagieren und mit einem epidemiologen
als neuen gesundheitsminister die
lufthansa verschärft wegen der korona
krise ihren sparkurs so sollen mehr als
die bereits angekündigten 22.000
arbeitsplätze gestrichen werden
wie viele es insgesamt werden ist aber
noch unklar
außerdem soll die flotte noch kleiner
werden insgesamt 150 maschinen will die
lufthansa stilllegen
auch alle a380 bleiben erst einmal am
boden
der skandal um die wirecard pleite ist
noch lange nicht aufgearbeitet eine der
kernfragen wieso ist
nicht früher aufgefallen dass der
zahlungsabwickler in seinen bilanzen
getrickst hat das
bundesfinanzministerium gibt vor allem
den privaten wirtschaftsprüfern die
schuld doch ein papier das exklusiv dem
zdf vorliegt zeigt auch eine behörde das
ministerium selbst hat bei der aufsicht
offenbar geschlampt florian neuer mitte
2018 wirecard strukturiert seinen
konzern um und die
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht bafin muss
das unternehmen durchleuchten und drückt
dabei offenbar beide augen zu so zeigt
ein schreiben des finanzministeriums
dass dem zdf vorliegt anstatt wie
vorgeschrieben die letzten drei
jahresabschlüsse anzufordern begnügt
sich die bafin mit dem von 2017 auf die
anderen beiden wird schlicht verzichtet
das ist ganz fatal denn bei dieser
prüfung ging es ja gerade um die
bilanzen von wirecard und ausgerechnet
da hat die bafin systematisch
weggeschaut und das finanzministerium
von olaf scholz rechtfertigt das
vorgehen als üblich bei internen
umstrukturierungen neue vorwürfe auch
anderswo während angela merkel und ihr
wirtschaftsberater im september 2009 10
in china für wirecard werben will die
deutsche botschaft in peking das
unternehmen kurz danach nicht
unterstützen
der finanzreferent wand und bezieht sich
auf damals längst bekannte
presseberichte zu möglicher
bilanzfälschung
es ist schon sehr erstaunlich dass er
finanz attaché der botschaft in peking
offenbar besser bescheid war es als der
chef berater der bundeskanzlerin für
wirtschaftspolitik merkels sprecher
spielt den ball heute zurück zum
bundesfinanzministerium bmf zum
zeitpunkt dieser china-reise 2009 10
september lagen dem bundeskanzleramt auf
basis der informationen des bmf keine
anhaltspunkte über mögliche
schwerwiegende unregelmäßigkeiten bei
wirecard vor
wirecard einer affäre bei der bis heute
niemand fehler zugeben will
die tarifverhandlungen im öffentlichen
dienst stecken fest
deswegen soll es ab morgen erste
warnstreiks geben etwa bei kitas und
kliniken
für kommende woche sind dann größere
aktionen geplant
für die rund 2,3 millionen
heftigsten fordern die gewerkschaften
unter anderem 4,8 prozent höhere löhne
die arbeitgeber haben noch kein angebot
gemacht
seit wochen demonstrieren die menschen
in belarus friedlich für die demokratie
und werden dabei niedergeknüppelt und
festgenommen und seit wochen will die eu
auf wahlbetrug und gewalt des
lukaschenko regimes mit sanktionen
antworten
doch sie schafft es nicht mit einer
stimme zu sprechen heute appellierte
oppositionsführerin svetlana cihan offs
kaya in brüssel an die europäische
solidarität in london über die lage in
belarus berichten wollte
oppositionsführerin svetlana die hall of
skye heute bei ihrem besuch in brüssel
beim informellen frühstück mit einigen
außenminister machte sie
unmissverständlich klar was sie von der
eu erwartet
natürlich sind sanktionen sehr wichtig
für unseren kampf das ist die art von
druck mittel welches die sogenannten
autoritäten zwingen würde den dialog mit
uns zu beginn mit den sanktionen wollen
die eu-außenminister all jene bestrafen
die für wahlfälschung oder die
gewaltsame niederschlagung der
friedlichen proteste verantwortlich sind
seit august feilen sie an der liste und
so manch einer stellte sich am morgen
noch die frage ob mich herr lukaschenko
derjenige der hauptverantwortlich ist
ebenfalls von der europäischen union
sanktioniert werden muss durch zypern
blockiert wie solchen maßnahmen
überhaupt nur zustimmen wenn auch die
türkei sanktioniert wird die im
östlichen mittelmeer nach gas sucht
beide themen haben zwar nichts
miteinander zu tun aber sanktionen
können nur einstimmig beschlossen werden
enttäuscht der eu außenbeauftragte nach
der sitzung
wenn wir nicht in der lage sind das zu
tun dann verstehe ich völlig dass unsere
glaubwürdigkeit auf dem spiel steht
steak jetzt sollen es die staats und
regierungschefs am donnerstag richten in
sachen belarus blockiert die eu sich
weiter selbst
jetzt geht es um ein geburtstagskind das
vom alter her allerdings eher ein
rüstiger senior ist 75 jahre werden die
vereinten nationen in diesem jahr
vertreter von 50 staaten unterschrieben
im juni 1945 die gründung skater
heute gehören 193 nationen zur
gemeinschaft ihr friedenssymbol ist die
skulptur vor dem hauptquartier in new
york
sie zeigt einen revolver mit verknoteten
lauf johannes hano über ein geburtstag
in unruhigen zeiten so ganz anders hatte
man sich das jubiläum hier in new york
am hauptsitz der vereinten nationen
vorgestellt
die feierlichkeiten wurden wegen der
korona panini größtenteils in den
virtuellen raum verlegt grußbotschaften
per video aus aller welt gerade in
schweren zeiten brauche man mehr
internationale zusammenarbeit so der un
generalsekretär
und er verwies auf den bislang größten
erfolg der weltorganisation struktur
es hat zwei weltkriege und millionen
tote gebraucht und den horror des
holocaust wer sich die führer der welt
zur internationalen zusammenarbeit und
der herrschaft des rechts verpflichtet
haben diese verpflichtung hat früchte
getragen
der dritte weltkrieg den so viele
befürchtet hatten wurde verhindert auf
initiative der usa gründen 1945 in san
francisco 50 staaten die vereinten
nationen
und es ist us präsident harry truman
deren aufgabe eindringlich formuliert
[Musik]
einen weg finden krieg zu beenden seit
75 jahren bemühen sich die vereinten
nationen konflikte zu schlichten die
welt zu einem friedlicheren ort zu
machen oft nicht erfolgreich
ob syrien oder nordafrika die
weltorganisation verliert mehr und mehr
an bedeutung weil die vetomächte china
russland und die usa ihre nationalen
interessen über die der welt stellen und
wie zum beweis für die sinkende
wertschätzung schickt der amtierende us
präsident zum jubiläum nur seine
botschafterin und anders als die anderen
staats und regierungschefs noch nicht
einmal eine videobotschaft
blicken wir nach afrika und auf eine
seiner wichtigsten lebensadern den nil
der bringt derzeit nach wochenlangen
regenfällen allerdings vor allem leid
und zerstörung in katastrophalem ausmaß
der blaue und der weiße nil laufen über
und schaffen tödliche wassermassen heran
besonders bedrohlich ist die lage im
sudan nahe der hauptstadt khartum wo
beide flüsse zusammentreffen
uli gack berichtet hochwasser bis zum
horizont ungezählte siedlungen dörfer
ganze städte wie weggewaschen von solch
biblischer flut von der hauptstadt
khartum aus ist unser kamerateam 200
kilometer richtung norden unterwegs
überall nur wasser und mensch und tier
die flüchten vor den überschwemmungen
des nils dieser schlechten laune der
natur
größer in rachman landwirt sagt dass
seine familie seit ewiger zeit hier lebt
er kennt übliches hochwasser aber nicht
solch gewaltige flut das dorf ist
ausgelöscht fast alle häuser sind
eingestürzt die meisten hier sind
weggelaufen sie sind an einen sicheren
ort geflüchtet ein sicherer ort das ist
irgendwo ein höherer stelle in der wüste
oft es mangelt an allem nahrung und
sauberem trinkwasser
zuerst es bleibt nur putzen mangelnde
hygiene hat viele krank gemacht hilfe
kommt nur schleppend klagen sie die
überschwemmungen wohl die schlimmsten
seit 100 jahren dauern seit august die
lebensgrundlage hunderttausender ist
zerstört hunger droht sagen sie alles
plantagen dort landwirtschaftliche
flächen sagt abdel hamid vergangenes
jahr erst haben wir hier neue zitronen
bäume gepflanzt die sind nun alle
abgestorben weite teile des sudan sind
von extremen niederschlägen und
überschwemmungen betroffen entfernung
gibt es nicht die regenzeit dauert bis
ende oktober
nach was angeles dagegen bei der
diesjährigen emmy-verleihung
überraschend auch ein
ist nach deutschland und zwar an die
begehrte us fernseh auszeichnung bekam
maria schrader für die regie bei der
miniserie unorthodox corona bedingt
alles online publikum im saal gab es
nicht aber eine riesenfreude auch eine
hervorragende serie und nun zu dir
norbert und die tour de france die
gestern zu ende ging
das war ja eine ganz besondere tour weil
sie ganz im zeichen von corona stand ein
volksfest wie früher konnte es diesmal
ja nicht werden aber allen unkenrufen
zum trotz das sportliche kulturereignis
der franzosen es hat stattgefunden vom
start bis zum ziel in paris nicht
unbedingt triumphal aber bemerkenswert
146 fahrer haben es bis ins ziel
geschafft 30 ausgeschieden aber nicht
durch einen positiven corona befund ein
erfolgreiches hygiene konzept wo die
fallzahlen bedenklich sind werden ganze
anstiege geräumt es gibt aber noch viele
stellen mit zu engem kontakt zu den fans
die beiden slowenen poker und rockhits
stürmen voran lassen titelverteidiger
bernal weit hinter sich der kolumbianer
gibt in den alpen auf beim einzigen
zeitfahren am letzten berg der rundfahrt
verliert rock ridge das gelbe trikot an
seinen jungen landsmann eine
sensationelle wendung partie poker ist
mit noch nicht einmal 22 jüngster
gesamtsieger seit 1904 verpasste ziele
beim deutschen team bohrer hansgrohe
weder grünes trikot für kapitän sage
anliegen in ihren bennett noch
podiumsplatz für den verletzungs
geschwächten emanuel buchmann lohn
jedoch für großem kampfgeist lennart
kemmler gewinnt die erste alpenetappe er
könnte ein mann für die gesamtwertung
werden aber das ist noch zukunftsmusik
beim bundesliga auftakt am freitag gegen
schalke hatte es die münchner
führungsetage daheim auf der tribüne am
nötigen krone abstand fehlen lassen es
gab reichlich kritik heute hat sich die
bayern spitze dafür entschuldigt
ilkay gündogan von manchester city ist
als erster deutscher nationalspieler
positiv auf corona getestet worden
negativ dagegen die testergebnisse bei
timo werner und kai h was vom fc chelsea
die gestern an gegen liverpool
antraten und verloren und zwar durch
einen doppelpack von sah die oma nie der
typ stürmer der rats traf per kopf in
der 50 minute und in der 54 nach einem
schweren patzer von chelsea torwart
keeper liverpool trainer jürgen klopp
der strahlende sieger dieses
spitzenspiels das was von mir danken
arbeiter in dieser woche geht er zu ende
der sonne gespäht sommer und macht einem
wechselhaften und regnerischen herbst
platz wie das genau abläuft das erklärt
gleich katja hoffe das war es von uns
danke für ihr interesse
klaus weber erwartet sie gegen halb elf
zum heute journal
und hier geht es jetzt gleich weiter mit
unserem chor ohne spezial bis morgen um
dieselbe zeit einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren in dieser
woche wird der spätsommer vom frühherbst
abgelöst heute aber noch nicht da gab es
strahlenden sonnenschein vom schwarzen
meer bis zum ärmelkanal
in der kommenden nacht sinken die
temperaturen am oberrhein bis 14 grad
deutlich kälter wird es im wendland in
der altmark und in der lüneburger heide
mit vier grad
dort ist also vereinzelt auch bodenfrost
nicht völlig ausgeschlossen
der himmel dazu ist meist klar ab und zu
bildet sich aber auch dichter nebel wie
zb im emsland und auch an der donau und
am bodensee der tag morgen beginnt mit
viel sonnenschein wenn sich der nebel
aufgelöst hat dann aber quellen am
nachmittag noch einige wolken in
süddeutschland und dann kann es
regenschauer und gewitter geben
vielleicht mal über dem schwarzwald über
der schwäbischen alb am alpenrand aber
vielleicht auch auf der frankenhöhe oder
im steigerwald die temperaturen morgen
steigen noch mal auf 25 bis 29 grad und
nur entlang der küsten von ost und
nordsee und im südosten bayerns bleibt
es bei 22 bis 24 grad etwas kühler
am mittwoch ändert sich noch nicht so
viel am donnerstag aber setzt sich dann
langsam von westen kühleres wetter durch
und es wird auch endlich einmal regnen
schönen abend noch